هذا هو الطريق الأخير المؤدي إلى
ليسيرشانسك البريطاني الذي تحركت قواته بتركيز نادر
هنا وقد تطوق قريبًا
جيب مدينتين على نهر كنا
نقود إلى
القوات الأوكرانية التي رأيناها هنا
متوترة في بعض الأحيان
متوترة وهذا هو السبب
عبر النهر هنا  مدينة إشبيلية
دونيتسك المحاصرة أكثر فأكثر في
أيدي الروس أيا كان من تسأله ،
يمكننا سماع صوت إطلاق النار
باتجاه النهر أدناه جيدًا ،
قيل لنا إن الروس حاولوا بالفعل
الدخول إلى المدينة ويبدو أننا
ربما نشهد محاولة أخرى.  هناك
هذا الدخان بالقرب من أحد الجسور المتبقية
في المدينة ،
يصرخ مرافقتنا من الشرطة بطائرة بدون طيار
غالبًا ما تستخدم لتوجيه هجمات مدفعية ،
فنحن على أرض مرتفعة مكشوفين ومتناثرون ،
إنها قصة يأسين هنا
مما يجعل الناس يبقون وهذا
ما يجعلهم أخيرًا  يهرب
بعض الذين يبقون غاضبين بشكل متزايد
مما تبقى من الدولة الأوكرانية هنا
قتلت امرأة شابة هنا في اليوم
السابق بقذيفة
والسكان المحليين  أخبرنا ألا نصور قائلًا إن
الكاميرات اجتذبت القصف ،
إن المثابرة الدموية لروسيا والقوة
النارية الجامحة تحقق نوعًا
من الانتصار في الأنقاض التي يبدو أنهم
يعتزون بها ، كانت
هذه السينما عبارة عن ملجأ من القنابل
قال المسؤولون المحليون إنه من غير الواضح ما إذا كان
الجيش الروسي على علم عندما ضربت الضربة الجوية الضخمة.
لقد تم إفراغها
قبل أيام من ذلك ، وهو أمر مذهل كيف
تم إلقاء أجزاء كاملة من هذه السينما في
الحفرة هناك ، هذه هي شراسة
الغارات الجوية التي نراها هنا مصممة
ببساطة لإخراج الناس من هذه المدينة
أولئك الذين يقيمون بين شظايا الزجاج.
أشعر بالتخلي عن
العديد من الأشخاص بالفعل ، لكن لا يوجد غاز أو
ماء أو كهرباء أو أي شيء سألناه
عمال الإغاثة اليوم عندما سيعود الجميع
وقالوا إنه لم يتبق سوى
مدمني العاهرات ومدمني الكحول ،
مما يعني أن عمال الإغاثة قد غادروا
هنا.
التقطت بعناية
قطع الغارة الجوية التي شعرت
بالقوة الكاملة في شقتها المكونة من ثمانية طوابق
وهناك سيدة عجوز  الطابق الأول
وأنا مع ابني المعاق تقول إنه
لا يفهم حقًا الحروب التي
تحدث
في الهواء الفارغ إذا أخذ بوتين
هنا ، فقد يزعم أنه حقق بعض
أهدافه المخفضة في هذا الغزو ، إنه
الآن خيار لا يحسد عليه قادة أوكرانيا.
إذا كان هذا هو التل
سيموت رجالها ونسائها